what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and I'm actually recording this in a
hotel room so hopefully you guys can
hear the birds chirping and everything
but it unfortunately limits my ability
to process the audio and make it sound
like super polished and everything so
I'll do the best I can but we've been
covering like beyond omega-level mutant
right like a Marvel Comics we've been
covering mutants that are beyond Omega
level now for those of you guys who
renew hear the term Omega level is used
to define the power of a mutant in
relation to all other mutants mutants
that have the ability to fundamentally
reshape the planet Earth or to impact
the planet Earth in such a way to cause
extinction or a massive loss of life or
to just change the form and function of
the earth itself are generally
considered to be Omega level but only
insofar that for the most part their
powers affect the entirety of the earth
but not really anything else outside of
it beyond Omega level is basically
mutants that have the ability to in some
form or fashion alter and manipulate the
very fabric of reality itself so you
know Franklin Richards is beyond Omega
level because he can shoot real bullets
from a fake gun you know he can make
Galactus as Harold different things like
that the molecule man Owen Reese he's
not really a mutant but he's a beyond
Omega level threat just because of the
fact that he can turn a cat into a
teacup if he wanted to Eamon live you
know he manipulates the molecular
structure of matter no matter what
universe he's in and there's no limit to
the amount of matter he can manipulate
so he could change the entirety of the
universe if that's what he wanted to do
now in Marvel Comics where you have
Omega level mutants you also have Omega
level threats and those are basically
non mutants equivalent to omega-level
mutant in terms of their powers beyond
Omega level threats are people who are
not mutants but have a level of power
that makes them equivalent to beyond
omega-level mutant so again the molecule
man or Mad Jim Jasper's or somebody like
that in this video we're gonna be
talking about beyond Omega level Spider
Man particularly cosmic Spider Man now
beyond Omega level cosmic Spider Man is
one of the coolest things because it's
basically a version of spider-man that
becomes god it's crazy the kind of power
he possesses but the basis behind the PI
that the power that spider-man has is
rooted in something called the unit
power and the unit power is rooted in
something called the enigma force and
the Enigma Force is really just this
energy force that Marvel's never really
bothered to explain we know it comes for
the Microverse this tiny itty bitty
universe
inside the main Marvel Universe those
are the guys who saw the movie ant-man
if Scott Lang had kept shrinking down in
that movie he would have eventually
discovered the the Microverse it's that
small it's that miniscule but it's stars
and planets and life and all different
kinds of stuff it's literally a universe
but it's just insanely small in scope
we know the the Enigma force comes from
there but we don't really know who made
it we don't know if it's like you know
the micro versus equivalent of the power
cosmic we don't really know anything
about that but we do know that when it
comes to the unit power that the unit
power is more of like a like a sentience
or like a state of being it's an energy
force that people are imbued with
specifically it's designed to be a
guardian for the cosmic entity eternity
now it's kind of a weird situation
because eternity is the most powerful
being in the main Marvel Universe in
that particular universe in any one
universe eternity is the most powerful
cosmic being there
now people with like the Infinity
Gauntlet will be more powerful than
eternity there are some wildly powerful
beings like Mad Jim Jasper's but he's
not a cosmic being so in terms of the
cosmic entities eternity is the most
powerful out of all of them but the idea
here is that the unit power serves as a
protector of eternity which is kind of
strange because when you're as powerful
as eternity is it's like that image that
we've all seen where like Jason Momoa
has bodyguards but like he's bigger than
his bodyguards like he would protect
them better than they would protect him
but the fact remains that the Abuna
power basically just kind of appears in
a time of need and it's really just one
of those plot devices that Marwa comes
up with worth just like let's give this
character an insane amount of power and
the unit power will be the way in which
we do it no explanation really needed
that's really it the instance where
Spiderman became God took place during
his story called acts of vengeance and
acts of vengeance if I remember was like
this 12 part crossover event but it was
basically a circumstance where Loki had
brought together all these villains in
the Marvel Universe and the idea was
that he was gonna start facing him off
against heroes that they would normally
never face so think about like the
events that led into the original old
man Logan's story except this time it
took place way back when and it was all
led by Loki but it ultimately failed the
idea here was that Loki wanted to pit
spider-man against something called the
Tri Sentinel and the reason why was
because of the fact that spider-man had
had fought kingpin he'd fought a
majority of the villains and some former
fashioned he fought a good portion of
the villains who were part of the acts
of vengeance whether it was
he was you know fighting alongside the
Avengers albeit not really part of the
team whether it's because he had fought
alongside the Fantastic Four or he had
simply fought them on their own the fact
remains that he had fought a lot of
these different folks and so pitting him
against something like the Tri Sentinel
which was basically this amalgamation of
three different iterations of the
Sentinels as they'd been created over
the years the hope was that spider-man
wouldn't know how to cope with it and
the result was that it would lead to
spider-man being defeated the problem
with this is that where spider-man would
have been beaten he was suddenly imbued
with the power of Captain universe now
the way that this works is that when a
person is imbued with the unit power and
they become Captain Universe all the
memories and experiences of the past
captain universes are all intertwined
and then so basically what that means is
that spider-man as Captain universe
remembers everything from everyone who
had ever been Captain universe before so
he knows the lengths of the powers that
he can use in terms of what they could
do which means that if they had
super-strength spider-man now knows that
he has super strength if they were able
to warp reality spider-man now knows
that he can warp reality he maintains
all those memories and different things
like that but in terms of what it is
that makes him beyond omega-level to all
the different powers of Captain universe
have waxed and waned over the years in
context with the story which is to say
some stories right Captain universe to
be a lot more powerful than he is in
previous iterations when Spiderman was
Captain universe he was basically God he
could manipulate matter on a universal
scale he could basically do anything he
wanted to he could bestow powers to
others he could take those powers away
he could heal people who were on the
brink of death he had no need for any
you know food water any of that kind of
stuff almost unlimited strength there
was actually one instance where he
punched the Incredible Hulk into orbit
virtually unlimited durability he could
fly beyond the speed of light energy
projection abilities that would rival
that of even Galactus it was crazy the
level of power that he had and so
because of this spider-man as a you know
as Captain universe was basically beyond
Omega level because what this meant was
that he had a level of power that was
unrivaled he was more powerful than like
any of the other beings that we've seen
so far in terms of you know just
powerful people from Planet Earth he was
more powerful in Franklin Richards
Matthew Molloy because really Matthew
although I didn't know how to use his
powers what the spider-sense for example
the spider sense of Peter Parker had as
Captain universe was pushed to the
extreme so where he would normally walk
around
is his normal self without the unit
power he would walk around and somebody
would you know pull out a gun and try to
shoot him his spider sense would tingle
and he would be aware to what that guy
was doing as cosmic spider-man he was
aware of virtually everything he had a
cosmic awareness and what cosmic
awareness meant was that he knew
everything that was going on in the
universe at any one particular point in
time now most anybody who has universe
spanning powers has some ability when it
comes to cosmic awareness I mean
molecule man has him Franklin Richards
has own quasar had it you know I'm
marvel of the Kree had a cosmic
awareness is just kind of this wild
power that's given to people where they
basically know everything that's going
on in the universe at any one particular
time but when you combine that with
everything the Spider Man could do it
was insane I mean the ability to warp
reality on a universal scale to do
anything with the universe that he
wanted to unlimited strength unlimited
durability unlimited stamina
instantaneous healing factor energy
projections that could destroy planets I
mean it was crazy all the different
abilities that he had now the way that
the unit power works is that it only
stays bonded with a person for any
period of time but it's limited based on
two factors the first is that the need
for captain universe basically ends and
so if it were some being that showed up
but had the ability to destroy the
planet Earth and Captain universe shows
up and says okay I'm going to bond with
spider-man in order to stop the Tri
Sentinel then once that that threat is
eliminated then the powers of Captain
universe go away the unit power
basically just dissipates and it leaves
that person the only other instance is
if a person tries to use the powers for
evil because remember the captain
universe abilities the unit power is
sentient it can think it has its own
rationale it has its own line of logic
we've seen that over the course of
marvel's publication history but it
really hit home during the events of
Johnathan Hickman's run on Avengers and
New Avengers which led up to the
collapse of the multiverse when a new
captain universe showed up but the woman
had been in a car crash and she was in a
coma and so when it got to the point
where the incursions were happening and
the various Earth's were crashing into
each other the unit power bonded with
this girl who was in a coma and then
basically woke her up and so whenever
you had like shang-chi who was speaking
with this girl trying to figure out who
she was every once in a while the girl
would go away and then the unit power
would step in and start speaking in her
place and so the unit powers sentient it
has its own desires and ambitions but is
only to be used for good it's never to
be used for evil and so because of that
if somebody were to try to use it for
evil deeds the unit power would just
dissipate he would abandon them and
would either go find a new host or he
would simply just go away in its
entirety but again that's the whole idea
of beyond omega-level threat when it
comes to Spider Man as cosmic Spider Man
he was limitless there was nothing he
couldn't do he was basically God in
terms of all the forms and fashions and
powers that he had available to him the
only major thing that he could not do
that virtually any other major cosmic
entity can do is resurrect the dead he
couldn't bring a person back from the
dead but aside from that he could do
virtually anything you wanted to but
with that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here - comments explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]